[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the new secrets of dumbledore
trailer and the absence of certain
characters yesterday i released a video
discussing the absence of porpin tina
goldstein a seemingly main character
from the fantastic beasts films released
thus far
more specifically i speculated as to why
she didn't make it into the trailer and
if she would be returning to the
franchise at all if you want to know
more about that check out the link in
the pinned comment but here's the thing
tina wasn't the only character missing
from the trailer how about oh i don't
know nagini before the trailer was
released at all there's a lot of hearsay
that she wouldn't be in the film
and i wasn't quite sure what to make of
it but now that she's been excluded from
the trailer i'm inclined to think that
the rumors were actually true again this
still isn't confirmed information but
it's looking pretty likely and it lines
up with the fact that actress claudia
kim has not been confirmed to be
reprising her role
it also lines up the fact that neither
the film nor kim's imdb profiles have
any indication of her playing nagini
kim has only been in one film so far the
second and she's already had quite a big
impact on the story
getting close with credence who is
central to the story so i wonder what's
going on here we know that later on once
the harry potter story's timeline sets
in that nagini becomes a prevalent
character voldemort's trusty serpentine
companion she becomes entirely
instrumental in voldemort's return to
power and her venom is even used in
elixir that allows him to rebuild his
strength but when the crimes of
grindelwald ended nagini wasn't trapped
as a snake the result of her maledictus
curse she was still able to transform
into a woman she also didn't appear to
be evil in any way crimes of grindelwald
made me feel bad for nagini
so when did she turn bad there's clearly
a lot of her story still to tell and i
for one am curious as to what happens to
her in this void between 1927
when she's last seen in crimes of
grindelwald and 1994 when she reappears
in harry potter there are also supposed
to be five fantastic beasts films in
total spanning 1926 to 1945 but again
this hasn't been confirmed either
what do you guys think has nagini been
scrapped i think she's a great character
and removing her would do the franchise
a great injustice if she doesn't appear
in secrets of dumbledore i hope she at
least shows up in the next films what
other lingering questions do you guys
have about the trailer about the secrets
of dumbledore film please comment them
down below as i'll be covering the films
a lot over the next week or two however
don't worry i'll be delivering regular
harry potter content as well if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember
words are in my not so humble opinion
our most inexhaustible source of magic
[Music]
you